[Музика]
немає шерифа: ти просто ми правдивий
підступний я з жахливої трійки прищів, яка по
ачить лань меншого класу, а стане еп
зодом Коттрелла, Коно проковтнув Аміну, що
роцедура розуміє, о, не преміум ко
на розмова з вашою системою віртуальна  sn-
jia випробування негативне кількість у roni
katya roni здібності вона дивиться на надійну
екстатичну метафору що відволікає через
Сатурн у кумазава Стенлі зламаний
сценарій навмання
[Музика]
привіт усім, пора уроку англійської мови
мене звати Наталія лешка
давайте почнемо я так  радий знову бачити Діму
в моєму класі привіт Діма привіт
зайчик Наталія як ти сьогодні
дуже добре дуже добре приємно що з тобою
як ти почуваєшся сьогодні добре
чи супер круто ми продовжили розмову
про Великобританію та Україну сьогодні ми зосередимося на
Україні та  ми знову граємо в гру, тож
давайте почнемо сьогодні, це буде
настільна гра, ви можете слідкувати за нами і грати
разом зі своєю сім'єю або з
друзями Діма, у вас дошка
перед тобою ок  y - божевілля так, це
схоже на те саме, і я маю це на
дошках для вас, так що Діма, ви перемістіть
свою лічильник з Vivid це для вашого
майбутнього кухаря, і у вас є грати в кубики,
і це буде для мене і
для студентів  щоб вони бачили добре, я
переміщу його на дошці, тому у нас є 19
питань, також номер три і номер
чотири, оскільки ви бачите, що номер три - це завдання
для вас, номер 14 буде переміщено
назад, перемістіть назад, Хасан Азад і 8 і
16  буде рухатися вперед добре
решта цифр - це питання
безпечніше дослідження Патанії дає
майбутнє або кранінг давайте почнемо так що кидаємо
кубики добре добре
давайте підемо номер п'ять п'ять фантастичний один
два три чотири п'ять питання номер п'ять
так чи є  пустеля або напівпустеля в
Україні у неї є черепно-мозковий кал Стелла
не повинна бути морозом Елла так чи ні Діма
так так абсолютно правильно, тому якщо ви
відповідаєте однаково, ви переміщаєте свою країну на
номер п'ять один два три чотири п'ять
і переміщаєте свою фішку Діма  лічильник о  не
два три чотири п'ять
за п'ять товарів фантастичний, так це і
це піски Аляски, вони утворюють
найбільшу відкриту ділянку піску в Україні
і другу за величиною в Європі, тому вона
тут знаходиться під Сонячним регіоном біля нижньої
течії Дніпра і
розкинута  на площі 1612 квадратних
кілометрів Анушка-Сендс — це не
зовсім пустеля, температура та
кількість дощу, що випадає в цьому районі, роблять його
напівпустелею, ландшафт пісків Аляски
складається з піщаних дюн
, висота яких може досягати 5 метрів  ти коли-небудь
відвідував Альошку відчуваю, що це не по-
італійськи це справді цирк Тимінський
згоден з твоєю зоною добре, якщо підійти ближче до
карткової системи я б досить Голлівуд
опублікував у Правді твій пост в історії з
огляду на український стиль вона розмовляла африканські
лижі постинг мир круто tommooch
кліп  Немо так дуже гарна Україна ця
велика країна, у нас тут є все
це я люблю тебе Україну я люблю,
тож ходімо далі, ви знову всі кубики так,
док один, так що це goi  ng бути
питанням номер шість, тому місцеві люди називають
озеро сінха пиво морське OKO це
правда/неправда, що ви думаєте з
chena brag, чи вона сумує за всеволодом
середнього або нульового сенатора морське OKO
Розлучений Одаджян Скайріма дев'ять, ви
вирішили втратити ще не  тато, так,
це правильна відповідь, тому, якщо ви відповідаєте
однаково, ви рухаєте лічильник чому, тому
що посеред озера є маленький острівець
, тому воно виглядає як
око, якщо ви подивитеся на око, чому я
[Музика]
у  цей регіон так, звичайно, у нас є
озеро, а посередині ми маємо
маленький острівець, тому його називають
Muscat oakum, спостерігаючи за Кріссі,
молодець, ти перемістила лічильник до шести так, ми
продовжуємо шість, тепер кидайте кістки знову,
так що  що знову номер один,
тож ми переходимо до питання номер сьом
давайте йти сім назв річок в
Україні Nisbet whisk українська ти перетворишся на
один два три зараз чи мій ти мені відповідай
Про добре просто не добре так добре
подивіться на мої річки нові  Pro the dis
n  ах, гарний пане, тому що я сказав вам минулого
разу дуже мудро, що з річками ми
використовуємо статтю добре,
багатий спокій не так багато спостерігайте, я
о, ах, розгромна стаття vet knee pro,
повторіть, будь ласка, сказав це зараз вони просто
мертві, містер фантастичний  Чи можете ви зробити
це швидше,
дуже дякую, тож давайте рухатимемося,
перемістіть свою лічильник до числа сім
фантастично і знову киньте кістки док
один два три чотири п'ять шість сім вісім
дев'ять п'ять добре, тож ходімо зі мною 1 2 3
4 5 7 плюс  5 є 12, тому ми відповідаємо на
запитання номер 12 добре яке
найглибше озеро в Україні найглибше озеро
в Україні давайте подивимося у нас є 2
варіанти, наприклад, перемикає ноги будь-де, що
ви думаєте, що найглибше мої губи
чудові настільки серйозні давайте перевіримо  солодке
солодке глибше так, це
найглибше Я сказав, що ти залишайся тут на
запитання № 12, і ми йдемо далі,
тож ходімо, ти йдеш до 12
Діма 12 добре так, а тепер ви всі
хлопці добре Голокост знову це добре для
чотирьох фантастичних 12  плюс 4 це 6
Де  так, так добре, і якщо ви
подивитеся на карту, подивіться 16, там написано, що вам
потрібно перейти до 19, це дуже велика
відповідь 19 назвіть тварин, яких ви можете
знайти в Scania Nova, чи знаєте ви
тварин, яких ви можете знайти  подивіться Scania Nova,
я допоможу вам, не хвилюйтеся, якщо ви
знаєте відповідь, ви вже можете перемістити
свій лічильник, якщо ви не послухаєте мене,
спочатку я прочитаю для вас текст, добре,
ви послухайте мене, а потім назвіть
тварин  Я звернувся до вамп-експресу, чи можете
ви знати додатковий бустер khalipa Truett Tauron
Stevie, будь ласка, ага,
так давайте перевіримо, що Scania Nova
вважається найстарішим природним заповідником в
Україні та найбільшим серед європейських
заповідних територій, заповідник займає
площу 11 000 га, де він є домом для
більше 400 видів трав і
квітів частини заповідника, що охоплюють
площу близько 150 видів дерев, у
тому числі ялівці в'язи перший і клени,
більше 60 видів птахів і багато
видів ссавців живуть у парку
відвідувачі заповідника  Ви, ймовірно,
побачите красивих птахів, таких як білі та
чорні лебеді та фламінго, а також
орли-
шапки. Серед тварин у заповіднику є верблюди, лами, буйволи
та дикі коні, туристи можуть оглянути
певні частини заповідника пішки на
конях або на туристичних автобусах, тому
яких тварин можна знайти в
Innova Carlos, добре, лами, хороший буйвол,
буйвол, і справжні коні, і дикі
коні, і дикі коні
.  збалансована Емма
так, тому краще мати 12 балів, щоб
інші тварини в заповіднику включали
верблюдів, лам, буйволів і диких коней,
ваша відповідь була дуже приємною, тому ви
вже на фініші, фантастично,
поверніться до тексту про Scania Nova
і я  хочу запитати у вас про дерева,
які ви можете побачити чи можете ви знайти
інформацію в тексті подивіться
швидко подивіться Діма В'яз спочатку ялівці та
клени я вам допоможу це
дерева добре подивіться, це гм, ми
називаємо це так, так, наступний ялівець
це yel Yvette's і останній -
клени,
це клановий сироп, це мій улюблений
, ти любиш кленовий сироп, я люблю тебе,
Клер, тому знову В'яз повторює  задоволений
Острови фантастичні, і ти став добрим наступний
Ялівець Ялівцю фантастичний ти повертаєшся
скажи знову Ялівець дякую і
останній клени клени дякую,
твоя черга клени добре, тому я хотів би
мати з вами фізичну перерву, ви не
проти добре, добре, давайте  подивіться
неправильне дієслово gymnastic так що ви переглянете
разом з нами ви
reverbs gymnastic let's go з дієсловом
go ready go ready go go go go go
gone huh you do with us go
go gone
дякую наступний let's go з дієсловом sleep
ти любиш спати  ти любиш мене спати
або ти любиш, коли ти спиш о, я люблю
тебе я люблю я люблю спати спати я
люблю спати фантастично, так що спати давайте
підемо слизь слизь слизь ковзай слип ти
повторюй за нами слизь спав добре спав
давайте з ано  ther work cut cut reset
a cut cut cut cut cut cut cut cut and you make
разом з нами cut cut cut good now
the work take let's go take brad take
take take take take take take take take a you
repeat take take взял взяв дякую дуже
дякую  дуже добре добре зараз я
б хотів, щоб ти відповів на це питання
розкажи про своє улюблене місце в
Україні Діма яке твоє улюблене місце
в Україні але подивлюсь на череп з ракети
я люблю тебе ти не кажи я люблю
тебе ти скажи я люблю  я люблю київ
вітаю Україну гарна міс belever гарна
залиш добре так карпаччо конденсатор
конденсатор конденсатор ємність ємність
ну ой так так буде розвиватися як
похід буп - вона я дивлюся нову блакитну
правду ти б мені розказав чи
Будду  на кран ні бла в основному бачив
Тамару, але це невідомо, поки я можу керувати
ним, тому NASA подібні дослідження руху так,
пані, так що ви можете сказати я
дуже люблю Україну я дуже люблю Україну
фантастично
добре і так, давайте подивимося  на
цьому  питання названі міста, які починаються
на К в Україні, але
найоптимістичніший Рене капуцин чужий
літературний запит, якщо не прийди сюди добре
Крик Крик константинівка добре Камінський
Бєлінський добре, але це насправді
дуже складне питання, якщо ви думаєте
про літеру К думайте про світ
Гарк, якщо ми вимовляємо це Harkov зі
звуком бух, але перша літера, коли ми
пишемо це K, то подивіться, що
її gif також починається на K тут, так далі
також починається з k, а molinski також
починається з k, так що це цікаво Київ,
але hark  якщо мм-хм,
це добре так так добре, тепер добре
Діма давайте відповімо на питання, на яке ми
не відповіли, ми виконуємо на
людській природі putana, будь ласка, добре, тому ми не
відповіли на питання номер два, давайте
подивимося, що таке прозорість
вода в озері найсолодше найсолодше є
найбільшим і найглибшим озером в Україні, у
ньому дуже чиста та прозора вода,
тому подивіться на відповіді до двох
метрів до чотирьох метрів до шести мультиметрів
до ei  ghtmeters, яка, на вашу
думку, правильна відповідь
a BC або D Діма як ви думаєте, що ви
можете кинути зворушливу книгу
Лука я знаю, що ви не там, добре так, я
думаю, що це речення допомогло вам,
тому що це найбільше і
найглибше  озеро право так до восьми метрів
добре ми не відповіли на питання номер
чотири давайте подивимося
оптиміст в печеру це печера
бечара оптимізація печера це гіпсова
печера біля села Чора
лефке Тернопільської області загальною довжиною
230 кілометрів це найдовша у
світі гіпсова печера, там можна знайти
питну воду, яка є рідною для занурення
, але невадо так чи ні, справжнє чи
хибне вундеркінд без проблем оптиміст,
кинь печеру
добре, я думаю, що крім назви
печери, ти допомагаєш оптимісту -  не оптимістичний
так, так що ви можете знайти питну воду там,
це справді цікаво
, ви бували оптимістом у печері,
назва Рікола, але повірте їм,
ми обидва ваші Нопалеа знаєте, що ваше
ні, будь ласка, хлопці змінюйте кожен
офіційно будь-хто дух Яма чоботи
Мюррей взяв кінорежисера добре ти тотем
вітаю тебе
Богарт такий веселий, я б сказав, що ти повинен знати,
що ти відчуваєш, коли отримуєш стипендію, щоб
ти міг сказати, що я відчуваю себе незручно,
незручно, незручно,
незручно.
тепер
добре, більше, ви все одно очевидно, ніколи не
збочуєте, просто у мене є прокурор, але Шаста,
що ви не Prescott boost так, я
згоден,
вам пощастило, хлопці, отримали позитив, що
скажіть на
запитання номер дев'ять ми не відповіли на
це як довго гарний Троцький каньйон  скільки
часу це подивіться 250 кілометрів
бути 350 кілометрів див. 450 кілометрів або
D 550 кілометрів у вас є хтось
там, впевнений, о ні, це 250 подивіться,
це не так довго, так 250
кілометрів, але це кілометри, а
не метри, це  так добре, ми
так не відповіли на питання № 10 що
таке салата Ліпа там багато
стрибає що це Розаліта
так ні
не дуже торкніться Гілліп ми подивимось у нас
є мистецтво  icle there не пам'ятаю, ми
переглянули, що ми використали артикул там
з назвою річки, тому Lata
liebe — це річка, це річка, це річка, це
річка в цьому регіоні, знову в
ємності, є багато lipeh розчинна речовина
Ali Pasha Sirota liebe тоді Джо
Lhota liebe liebe salata Реба знову повторює,
що є багато Ліпа добре, ми
продовжуємо говорити про оптиміста в
печері, яка вам подобається, це правильно,
це було виявлено в 1699 році, ласкаво просимо,
улюблене створіння, якщо це справедливість,
навіть не стабільність, мородийна правда чи неправда,
що ви думаєте, Хема  правда чи неправда
блок ви повинні бути абсолютно впевнені печера,
яка поділяє оптиміст H зараз вступає
в тернопільську область таблиця cretin
Watauga do 1699 правда чи неправда практика
в проблемі але ні ні звичайно це не
було ні це не так рано
було  відкрито у 1966 році a versa у
1966 році чи можете ви повторити ще раз 1966 по 1966 рік
дякую дуже в 66
добре давайте подивимося на питання
номер 18 так назвіть моря України
моря марія марія крейн може  ти називаєш
морську воду добре англійською англійською
black okay
black Lexia that black the black sea так
цей рік özil так і ми говоримо sea sea
sea sea sea like a Tele black
see дивовижний і сріблястий вигляд я люблю
тебе чорні я люблю це  тут я
люблю Чорне море
я люблю Чорне море і мені подобається море
/ журнали Zohar Мені подобається морська нафта штату
Айова о, я люблю цей рік özil так, я
люблю,
мені подобається, що вони проводжають її, оскільки
дякую, це мені сподобалося  цього року офіцер
зараз zip скажи мені це подобається як молодець
і останнє питання на сьогодні номер
15 ми його не відкривали так назвіть перша
столиця України один два три п'ять
шість сім дев'ятнадцять двадцять двадцять
фантастичний так перша столиця
України  Персія, щоб їсти зеленіший
коракул так, Браво, добре, тому якщо ви
знову відповіли правильно, ви наберете
від мене бали, давайте переглянемо статті
з географічними назвами, тому з озерами,
наприклад, ми відвідали озера в коли-небудь, чи можете
ви повторити ще раз ми відвідали озера в
повітрі виявлення зла старший сен  ior добре
з горами окремі гори
ми не використовуємо статтю я бачив гору
говерлу зі свого дому я бачив гору говерлу
зі свого дому Діма чи
можна повторити я бачив свій від вас
додому з моєї хати з дому так з
містами селища та села  ми також не
використовуємо жодних статей він пробув у
Луцьку тиждень
минулого року він заявив Лутц за тиждень минулого
року Діма чи можна спробувати його стан на лютнях
на тиждень минулого року минулого року так і
з островами у нас є острови в
Україні  а також, наприклад, хоча
острів він є невеликим островом в
регіоні Маколіфф, острів Дові — невеликий острів у Мекці, живий острів
Собачий острів так, це маленька Ісландія
в міколі Червоного Джона
так, ти можеш повторити за мною острів
острів чи можеш ти  співайте слова давайте скажемо
голосно острови О фантастично,
так Остін, якщо острови Будди англіканський
острів острів острів офіційний острів Наташа
I, ми не вимовляємо як
острів острів острів так острови
фантастичні острови,
тепер давайте переглянемо артику  там з
географічними назвами, коли ми використовуємо
статтю, тому ми говоримо, що з річками
добре, що Негр є однією з головних
річок Європи, чи можете ви повторити, як будь-який
професіонал, або з болотних річок Європи
Європа Європа, хороші гірські хребти,
наприклад віскі  в ємності
віскі в основних питаннях
пропорції ємності Себастьян
Себастьян Себастьян Себастьян Віскі
в ємності з пустелею є пустеля
Аляски розташована в пагорбах
власний регіон чи можна спробувати
хвороба запустіння зеліха розташована
в людині досягає Брава з океанами і
морями чорні  море більше, ніж
азовське море чорні тут у почалося z0z
море азовське як офіс так і це слово
ми говоримо дивіться дивіться моррісі дивіться
Чорне море дешево італійське так Чорне
море Чорне море Чорне море
Чорне море і  Азовське
море Чорне море в генеральному директору розчиняється
як чорний генеральний директор і генеральний директор Oz все
добре
чую дзвін дзвінок нажаль
є дзвінок да урок бу  t Я
сподіваюся побачити, як він дивиться на це, дивлюсь, дивлюся
, що навіть дотик розрізає сковороду по-
італійськи - просто поставити монстра це
не говорити про що через coochie GD aviacode
сир Патріція Веласкес bTW civic
будь-яке місто англійська Джексон так, ти
починаєш говорити  як європейка Бріанна, ти
бачиш вушка, з'являюся я обожнюю Лондон О,
Скотт Бакула зденка капут
повз машину даніелевського так добре я дивлюся на
це милосердя
Наталія так науковець онлайн звичайно
добре побачимося наступного разу побачимося без бульбашки
носа дуже мінімальна робота, ви таргани
проповідь педагог дуже багато DG
епідермальний в щітці низькі собачки є
величезною проблемою наша парафія lo pasa amigo de
amalah eyah Шаміль Басаєв дивіться
вздовж цього напису Babu Willa gluten
[Музика]
you